this'll tell us about the structure
Foundation and some of the interesting
dynamics because in your foundation you
share leadership with your mother how
does that work I have any of you worked
with your parents before and Eddie
because it's it's it's rewarding and
challenging like at the same time so
what we did was in 2008 I decided a few
years earlier I kind of took control of
my wealth and I decided to take 50
million dollars and set up a foundation
and at that time I didn't really feel
like I had the skill set to lead that
and kind of manage that and it's
something I mean my mom is very is a
passionate philanthropist as well so she
is technically the president of the
foundation and I'm the vice president
and but we really work together on
setting the vision and the mission and
the strategy for the foundation but what
I kind of like about that is that I
myself from getting some leadership
development training you know because I
I've never run a foundation before and
so at least working at I think it's also
important not only to be a leader but
create development opportunities for you
as well because you you know you should
always constantly be learning so when we
set it up that way you know the goal is
and you know 10 years or so or whatever
less than that whenever my mom decides
to step down that I will then run the
foundation but I've liked actually being
in that number two position for these
early years because I'm learning a lot